forme de diffusion, Crave, qu'on
pourrait avoir la réunion de
Friends.
- J'avais mon DVD,
je l'écoutais tout le temps,
j'en écoutais deux par midi.
- L'autrice India Desjardins
a visionné la série "Friends"
plus d'une fois. Pour elle,
ce fut une véritable école.
- Il faut que je te dise
quelque chose de très important.
- Ça a fait partie de comment
je me suis formée, autant comme
personne que comme autrice,
parce que ça m'a appris
des façons de raconter des
choses de façon humoristique,
des conflits qui restent
dans le plaisir. C'était
la première série... "sitcom"
à mettre un arc dramatique
de saison. Ça, c'est vraiment
intéressant parce que tu n'as
pas ça dans les "sitcoms",
à part "Friends".
♪ ♪ ♪
- 25 ans après la diffusion
du premier épisode, les six amis
seront de nouveau réunis
à l'écran pour une émission
spéciale diffusée sur
HBO MAX aux États-Unis
et sur Crave au Canada.
Des retrouvailles très attendues
par les millions de fans
partout sur la planète.
À New York, les touristes
se font encore photographier
devant la façade du célèbre
appartement de
Greenwich Village.
♪ ♪ ♪
Selon le magazine "Variety",
les acteurs auraient été payés
2,5 millions $ chacun pour
participer à ces retrouvailles,
et en plus de la distribution
originale, 15 autres vedettes,
dont Justin Bieber,
David Beckham, Lady Gaga
et Malala Yousafzai
participeront à la spéciale.
- We became best friends.
- C'est que malgré le temps
qui passe, l'émission continue
de caracoler en tête des séries
les plus regardées sur
les plateformes de diffusion
en continu.
- Alors toi, si tu vas à cours,
c'est pour apprendre.
- Mais certaines blagues passent
moins bien aujourd'hui.
Des critiques ont déploré
le manque de diversité,
le caractère homophobes
ou grossophobe de certains
des vieux sketchs.
- Ça, c'est toutes
des critiques très légitimes
qu'on fait à la série, mais
qu'on peut contextualiser
par cette époque-là.
- Malgré tout, comme
des millions de fans,
India Desjardins attend
impatiemment ces retrouvailles
parce que les amis,
c'est pour la vie.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.